[Music]
on this monday night ditching the
classroom at the last minute for online
learning
the nervous parents changing their minds
and choosing to keep kids at home
and those who don't have any options i'm
just hoping
hoping for the best bc submerged in a
sea of smoke
it's off the chart in terms of how much
we should be breathing in
the alarming risk to people with chronic
illnesses and the grim
predictions for the future a popular
canadian co-op
sold to americans it's not what i want
what's in store for mek and its devoted
members
plus rain and open water instead of snow
and ice
a chilling report on the arctic's new
normal
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the topic we're all tired
of but
can't turn away from kovid 19 case
numbers keep
rising in some regions most of the
positive cases right now are in people
under the age of 40
but that can easily change as it spreads
through the community
ontario's premier has pleaded repeatedly
for people to stop going to big parties
today quebec's premier said even if
you're not worried about getting sick
yourself
consider others who you could
unknowingly infect
think about our vulnerable people
think about our children think about the
consequences of letting
your guard down so i'm asking people to
avoid
gatherings as much as possible
try to avoid contacts as much as
possible
so we have to react together
now over the past seven days an average
of 838 daily new cases have been
reported across the country
we haven't seen those kinds of daily
numbers since the end of may
the bulk of the newly reported
infections are in quebec
ontario alberta and bc there were 124
new cases in alberta
292 in quebec today 251 in ontario
and 97 in bc it is the fifth straight
day
of more than 200 new cases in ontario
most are in toronto ottawa and the peel
region premier doug ford says if that
continues
new targeted restrictions could be put
in place
the demand for covid19 tests is surging
as more canadians head back to work and
school
this was the scene this morning at one
of ottawa's main testing centers
the lines there have been so long people
sometimes have to wait for hours and
porta potties are now being added it all
adds up to an uncertain time
and that uncertainty is playing out in
schools across this country
students parents and teachers trying to
get back on track
knowing things can easily be derailed if
positive cases emerge
students in the toronto school district
began their return to class today
as jeff semple reports not everything
went as planned
canada's largest school board welcomed
toronto students back
to their new reality who's next greeted
with pylons
plexiglass and face masks can't see
anybody's faces
and then yeah it's gonna be a different
experience and for some students
back to school has already backfired
it is bound to happen one class at this
toronto area school was sent home to
self-isolate after one of their
classmates tested positive
in alberta which opened schools a couple
of weeks ago hundreds of students have
been forced to quarantine
with the climbing covid 19 caseload
thousands of parents across the greater
toronto area
are now changing their minds at the last
moment and signing their kids up instead
for remote virtual learning among those
opting for online learning
this toronto father of two kids are kids
right
in the school environment i know their
social distance rule there will be wear
masks
it will be tough i would say for the
kids his kids were supposed to start
remote learning this week but that's now
been delayed as the toronto school board
scrambles to accommodate a last-minute
rush
with 64-thousand students choosing to
learn
online as a result of the thousands that
are keeping their kids
away from school the result is that
classes are being collapsed class sizes
are going up
others have no choice but to send their
kids to school andrea wobik is a single
mother
and a lawyer you know i expect that
there are going to be stops and starts
and that's
very unfortunate but you know i'm just
hoping
hoping for the best and we'll have to
deal with whatever comes there probably
will be outbreaks
on and off in the schools but i think
after a while things probably will
settle down
and so far at least the vast majority of
covet 19
cases in schools have spread from the
community
not in the classroom jeff semple global
news
toronto another major story we are
tracking the wildfires on the u.s west
coast
dozens of major fires are still burning
and the devastation is spreading
now a group of canadians is headed south
to help the alberta government says 45
firefighters are traveling to oregon
this week to assist crews on the ground
there
this is what awaits them all along the
west coast from washington state to
oregon and down the coast of california
it is a battle to try to slow down
fast-moving fires
and limit the damage in parts of oregon
it's too late
at least 10 people are dead more than 20
others are missing
after entire communities were
incinerated
it's the worst thing i've ever seen in
my life is
i had seen videos but it's a thousand
times worse than i could have ever
imagined
across the three states at least 27
people are now confirmed dead
thousands of homes are destroyed and the
smoke gives you a sense of the scale of
this
it's visible right across the continent
now the smoke has drifted all the way to
the east coast with hazy skies reported
in toronto and new york city but the
worst effect in terms of air
quality is on the west coast in places
like vancouver pollution levels from the
fine particulate matter in the smoke are
so high
people are being told to avoid strenuous
exercise outside
robin gill explains what makes forest
fire smoke potentially dangerous
smoke has shrouded british columbia
blocking out vancouver's view
and creating concern for people who have
chronic illnesses we're most concerned
with the immediate effects of for people
that have pre-existing heart and lung
disease
or people with type 2 diabetes we do
know that events like this can lead to
increased deaths it's prolonged exposure
that will produce the most deadly
consequences
the fine particulate is so small not
only is it making it into your
your lungs but it's also going and
reaching into your bloodstream
and that's where damage to organs in bc
there are 31 monitoring stations that
determine
the air quality index a tube collects
the fine particulate known as pm2 the
particles are coming into the instrument
they're being measured on a tape that
gets darkened as it collects
the fine particulate matter and during
this time right now
we're seeing the tape get these dark
spots in ways that we haven't seen them
before
on a perfectly clear day an ideal
measurement is 5 to 15 micrograms per
cubic meter of air
the goal is to keep an average day at 25
but in the last few days bc has
experienced 150 to 170
on average it's off the chart in terms
of how much we should
be breathing in vancouver has opened up
clean
air centers to give people a chance to
breathe and get away from the haze
and there are dire warnings that there
will be a greater need for these spaces
in the future this is it this is reality
so we're just going to have to learn to
live with this
and probably it's going to get worse
scenes like this are grim when
vancouverites are trying to enjoy
the last days of summer robin gill
global news vancouver
a big win for canada today in a tense
trade dispute with united states
just before canada was set to announce
how it would retaliate for american
tariffs on canadian aluminum
the us blinked and backed down abigail
beeman joins me from ottawa abigail what
happened and what's the reaction
donna deputy prime minister christopher
freeland describes this as a good day
for canada a day where
common sense prevailed and she and the
international trade minister
stressed over and over this was a
unilateral move by the united states
canada will not be imposing reciprocal
countermeasures on the united states
let me be clear canada has not conceded
anything the government is clear they
are ready to impose
dollar-for-dollar counter tariffs if the
u.s strikes again
and the americans haven't taken the
trade threat off the table the statement
from the u.s trade representative
details that if canada exceeds a certain
quota of aluminum per month before the
end of the year
the americans will impose that 10
percent tariff retroactively on that
month and may
reimpose it fully going forward a
canadian source calls that bluster
we have not agreed to anything we have
not
negotiated an agreement with the u.s on
quotas
as your question suggested what has
happened today
is that the united states has chosen
to unilaterally lift its tariffs
on canadian aluminum exports to the
united states
the deputy prime minister wouldn't
answer whether canada is likely to
exceed the quotas set by the u.s
just stressed the american move was a
unilateral one
and canada hasn't negotiated a deal on
aluminum
donna all right abigail beeman in ottawa
thank you
lane higgs is settling in for a second
term as premier of new brunswick the
progressive conservative took a risk and
called an election during the pandemic
and it worked in his favor he not only
won a majority the campaign
and voting date went smoothly proving it
can be done
though as ross lord reports the results
reveal a divide in the province
as canada's only officially bilingual
province
new brunswick takes pride in harmony
between cultures
but the election outcome highlights
divisions francophone writings along
northern new brunswick went entirely
liberal red other parts of the province
mostly anglophone writings
have been painted pc blue the french
seem to be liberals and the
english seem to be more conservative
side so that
leaves a bit of you know
uncertainty i guess the good news the
unprecedented campaign went off with no
major disruptions as they claim success
new brunswick election planners also
have a word of advice
for other parts of canada be ready for
surprises
i think the mail-in ballots really is
the largest one prepare for a
significant increase in that
premier blaine higgs wrote a wave of
popularity for new brunswick's stifling
of covet 19
all the way to a majority i'm looking
for stability in all parts of the
province i'm looking for changing the
process that we haven't seen work
because people have left
the northern part of the world
particularly high unemployment rates
his main rival liberal leader kevin
vickers failed to convert his parliament
hill hero status
into success at the polls in fact
vickers lost in his own riding
i will be resigning as leader of the
liberal party of new brunswick
some wonder if higgs will use his new
authority to reimpose
a shake-up to health care that he backed
off from when he had a minority
they didn't say oh this was a terrible
idea we will never do it again
so uh i am not reassured now that
they're in a majority higgs insists
he'll consult others to seek consensus
on issues
before he takes action ross lower global
news
fredericton new brunswick a positive
development today in the case of alexi
navalny the russian opposition leader
who was poisoned
he has regained consciousness navalny
posted this from his hospital room
saying
i have been missing you i still can't do
much but yesterday i managed to breathe
on my own for the entire day
navalny was flown to berlin after
falling ill on a domestic flight in
russia on august 20th
three labs have independently verified
he was poisoned by a form of the nerve
agent novochuck
his family believes the kremlin ordered
the poisoning the kremlin denies that
navalny says he intends to return to
russia when he recovers
big changes coming next who's taking
over this outdoor retailer and canadian
co-op
opposition is growing to a deal that
will privatize a popular canadian
retailer
mountain equipment co-op announced it's
being taken over by an american
investment firm
a petition calling for the deal to be
canceled already has over ten thousand
signatures
mack as it's known was born nearly 50
years ago as a grassroots cooperative in
vancouver
customers bought five dollar memberships
to become part of the co-op essentially
owners of the company
and as mike derolay reports seeing where
it's headed hurts
for almost 50 years mec customers have
shared a bond in ownership
and pride in a socially conscious
company that was uniquely canadian
so news of a takeover by american
investment firm kingswood capital
came as a shock it's not going to be the
same as it has been like it's a company
that
i love and trust mec had to close all 22
of its stores and lay off 1300 employees
because of the pandemic
but it's true financial troubles can be
traced back a few years
to when it began aggressively expanding
into more big
box stores at a time when consumers were
moving to more online shopping
mech grew its outdoor specialist
business by selling five dollar
memberships to like-minded customers
but in 2013 it removed the co-op from
its logo
and expanded its product lines going
more mainstream in the process
that's what the market wants isn't it
it's not
what i want ultimately mech sales
couldn't match its growth the board of
directors thought that for them there
was
no other way or no other option that
were viable
in order to keep the company afloat so
that the company could survive
because otherwise they would have to go
bankrupt so mac will continue
to exist although the new owners are
expected to close five stores and cut
25 percent of its workforce and those 5
million memberships
they'll soon be worthless the new owners
have said they're going to keep the name
they're going to keep the some of the
same brands so i think it's going to be
very similar
it's just not going to be members
helping members and if that was
important to you
you're going to notice that difference
as a customer not a member
microlight global news toronto
climate change still ahead the latest
signs of how the arctic
has been altered
you're watching global national
[Music]
the signs are everywhere we know the
arctic is changing and now a new report
from america's national center for
atmospheric research
says the effect of global warming is so
severe the region is actually
shifting to a different climate open
water and rain are becoming more typical
of the region than ice and snow
eric sorenson explains the findings and
what they mean for the future
the arctic a massive part of canada's
geography
with a consequential impact on our
climate is changing
rapidly so quickly a new study suggests
the arctic may already be transitioning
to a new climate
not perpetual ice but more water and
snow giving way to more rain
it means the past may no longer be a
predictor because the climate may now be
that different from the past
the arctic has warmed so significantly
that it's year-to-year variability
is moving outside the bounds of past
fluctuations
signaling that it's transitioning to a
new climate since the 1970s
satellites have been able to show us the
arctic ice cap melting somewhat every
summer
and then the ice cover increasing each
winter but
over the last 40 years nasa says the
summer minimum the red line
shows the sea ice gradually shrinking
overall arctic sea ice has declined
12 percent per decade and the smallest
13
summers of ice have all occurred in the
last 13 years
greenpeace has been navigating the
arctic for decades and they've seen the
changes
i'll say like the permanent ice edge
that exists it's getting smaller and
smaller every year
these are the waters off baffin island
99 percent of canadians do not live in
the arctic
so we're not seeing firsthand the open
waters the melting sea ice
and the loss of polar bear habitat the
new research
uh is yet another important piece of
evidence showing
that it's really time we stop hitting
the snooze button and wake up to the
climate emergency
the signs are all there last month a
huge 113 square kilometer piece of
greenland's
ancient ice sheet broke off clearing the
way for more ice loss into the sea
greenpeace wants to create ocean
sanctuaries areas protected from oil
drilling and pollution
and they want political leaders in this
country and elsewhere to act
now we want to make sure that world
leaders
understand the urgency of the climate
crisis and they understand the role of
the
of healthy oceans in tackling the
climate crisis
there's no longer much debate that the
arctic climate is changing
the new research suggests what may be
more difficult is forecasting just how
quickly
eric sorensen global news toronto
the state of the planet's ecosystems and
biodiversity is also in peril a new
report from the united nations says not
a single target has been met
in the 10 years since nearly 200 nations
agreed to take steps to prevent the mass
loss of wildlife and natural habitats
those steps included slowing
deforestation limiting overfishing and
preserving wetlands and marine
areas there has been some progress but
the report says biodiversity will
continue to decline on the current
trajectory
concerns were also raised about hundreds
of billions in government subsidies for
fossil fuel and other industries
that harm the environment next the
potential crisis
at the polls as u.s election workers
face the pandemic
in 50 days we'll know whether president
trump will spend another four years in
the white house
and the build up to the presidential
election is fraught with anxiety
not only is the country deeply divided
politically there's
unrest because of police brutality and
racism and
then there's the pandemic tens of
thousands of people have dropped out of
plans to work at polling stations
because they fear being infected
as jackson proskow reports it's calling
into question whether the election will
be free
and fair when she returns it
what do you think she does in there it's
training day in the baltimore suburbs
there's balance in here where poll
workers known as election judges
are learning how to hold a vote in the
middle of a pandemic
the biggest challenge has been educating
everybody about all the changes
and here officials in maryland were
already bracing for unprecedented
interest in this election
then came kovid 19. we need about 40
000 election judges to hold the election
we saw about 15 000 of them drop out
all at once so in our world that
constitutes an unprecedented
emergency the majority of poll workers
are over 60
the group at highest risk for severe
illness from the virus
i'm going to be 80 in november and it
just
seemed to me a little bit
doubtful whether i should be out sitting
in a room
eleanor greene is one of those
volunteers who reluctantly decided it
was better to sit this one out
even if you're just giving out i voted
stickers you're still
in reasonably close contact with people
trying to do all of this
six feet apart seems a little difficult
without election judges most polling
locations can't open
so states have had to get creative in
maryland instead of the usual 3 400
polling sites there will be just 260
super poles
at places like the 80 000 seat fedex
field
home to washington's nfl team election
officials are also encouraging people to
vote by mail
it'll end up being a rigged election or
they will never come out with an outcome
with the president baselessly
undermining the process there's another
challenge
convincing people their votes will still
be counted fairly
there haven't been many instances where
people have successfully
used vote by mail to commit voter fraud
in just this one county
half of eligible voters are expected to
vote by mail
the rest will experience an election
unlike any other in american history
one where the virus is an issue both on
the ballot
and at the ballot box jackson prosco
global news
glen burnie maryland and that is global
national for this tuesday i'm donna
friesen
thanks for watching we leave you tonight
with a tribute to aileen crecher the
wife of former prime minister
jean-claude
a private funeral was held today in the
couple's hometown of sherwin again
quebec
aileen creche died peacefully on
saturday morning just days after the
couple celebrated
their 63rd wedding anniversary
[Music]
you